what's up guys wave function is e so we
have just it to 800 K subscribers and a
lot of you guys wanted to see two versus
one giant ping pong so here we go so
it's me versus me in the middle let's go
we tapped moose this one you will okay 0
0
Oh
this way too easy for me it was like a
connection last moment I don't know what
I was thinking
- mmm
no I was like in slow motion
[Music]
go
this crazy around here
that's the sports I wanna player
we can do this all day
hot damn oh [ __ ] it
[Music]
No
I can do this
goodnight
[Music]
of course
fake shot it's hard as hell talk--i they
still have no time
much special methylation
yeah it may actually make the sensei run
there
[Music]
what am I even doing here
I could have saved it from there we play
every shot in the middle look he doesn't
even have to move okay now let's only
play out two corners
come on
oh I was actually trying to do the fake
shots today
tip
maybe
okay so we didn't get as much advantage
as we were hoping hoping to get but that
was surprisingly difficult to play with
with two players mixing up each other
was easy but yeah subscribe here and
watch the previous episodes there I'll
tell you next time